hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute ein horrorspiel das spiel was wir
heute spiel heißt er an
where is no hay auf der website auf den
ich dieses spiel gefunden habe stand
dass dieses horror spiel fünf sekunden
dauert entweder ist es übels gruselig
übels geil oder übel scheiße wir
scheißen einfach auf die hilfe und
klickt man direkt auf start und ich bin
okay ich kann mit der sdk nicht laufen
jetzt irgendwann sich paare linie ich
komme mir irgendwie nicht weg ich möchte
viele fragen mich immer wo ich diese
tollen spiele finden hier drin
tatsächlich das spiel ist gerade
ernsthaft abgestürzt nachdem ich
gewonnen habe ich klicke einfach für die
hilfe hahn umzusehen
du kommst jetzt
gibt es da keine möglichkeit dass sich
das irgendwie schaffe komm schon luca
konzentriere dich darauf dass einfach zu
schaffen ich drück jetzt mal hws de to
move escape to quit game trailer escape
the beast
das habe ich doch alles gemacht los luca
lauf lauf lauf lauf in wir haben
geschafft was geschafft mein gott ich
habe schon zwölf sekunden mehr überlegt
gibts horror kanäle auf youtube kann ich
einer von euch werden wenn ich mir das
hier mal angucke habe ich dann merkt da
habe ich die app die konnten ja das ist
schwachsinn dann werde ich zurück in
randen website die habe ich eine website
auf der ich das zocken kann und bei
windows habe ich die echse und wenn ich
dann in der dort exe-datei drin wenn sie
das ganze so aus
hilfe ich hab so angst vor dem
horrorspiel mich würde mal interessieren
ob wirklich fünf sekunden dauert bis man
da stirbt deswegen klicke ich wenn ich
da gespannt bin auch hier mal eben
schnell auf staat deswegen staat sorgt
sagt ich bin ein sportler für keine
richtung und
fünf sekunden 58 ist es definitiv das
kürzeste horror spiel aller zeiten
wissen wir viele fragen mich immer wie
man auf youtube gute video
keine ahnung wie wir ziemlich gut lauf
lauf blaufichte china nicht auf links an
ihm vorbei und dann laufe ich hier um
die kurve
ich führte es ja gern ich schaffe es
jetzt länger als zehn sekunden macht gar
keinen sinn weil ich glaube ich sogar zu
beginn schon länger als zehn sekunden
geschafft habe ich habe jetzt mal die
graphics aufs eis gestellt das heißt
wenn ich jetzt hier drin wenn sehen wir
schon die die die grafik verändert sich
kein stück es macht aber gar keinen sinn
da wir gar kein counter drin haben und
ich noch mit dem handy keinen counter
angemacht habe also kann ich mich
theoretisch einfach mal
daraus besteht wirklich das komplette
spiel
bitte
nee
wisst ihr dass er die größte scheiße ist
ich muss den schwachsinn jedes mal
wieder aufs neue staaten und
konfigurieren wir schreiben ja
tatsächlich immer recht viele leute dass
wenn ich mich sogar spieler aufregen
dass sie sagen dass es auch für sonnen
spieljahre dauer oder blogger minuten
dauert das zu programmieren ja freuen
ich habe er auch respekt für wenn man so
etwas programmieren kann aber wenn man
so etwas programmiert dann sollte es
doch wenigstens etwas vernünftiges sein
und nicht hier ich werde von einem
pinken setzt sich auch nicht als leben
ziehe ich programmiere ein horrorspiel
wo man von einem pinken quader verfolgt
wird und
dann kommt diese fresse und dann beendet
sich einfach das spiel oder ist deswegen
wieder lebenstraum von einigen von euch
ich habe jetzt mal die fantastic
graphics ausgewählt und werden mal
schauen ob jetzt irgendwas vom schnee
das spiel bleibt immer noch scheiße
wenn ihr das spiel gewinnen wollt dann
lauft einfach die ganze hätten große
runde im kreis
dann seid ihr sieg kann ich nicht
irgendwie den berg hoch oder irgendwas
hier macht
q
von dem schreck hatte ich tatsächlich
nicht gedacht ich beende das video an
dieser stelle hier weil ihr wollt es
doch auch nicht mehr sehen oder ich habe
dieses spiel auf dem gold gefunden und
da war es halt so dass wird kein bild
war und ich dachte es wäre ein horror
spiel und so ein horrorspiel wenn man
das vorher schon mal spielt er macht ja
keinen sinn wenn man es dann nochmal
zweite beispiel um aufzunehmen deswegen
habe ich jetzt einfach drauflos gezockt
nachhinein betrachtet wäre besser
gewesen wenn das ganze mal vorher
angeschaut hätte aber dann hab ich auch
name gestarteten mein gott ich bin faul
aber ich hab's dann einfach
weitergemacht wenn es euch gefallen an
den text mit einer bewertung wenn nicht
dann gibt daumen runter
aber bitte haltet einfach die fresse
nein das ist wieder so gemein ich darf
man nicht so gemein sein ich mag euch
hier ich zeige euch ukulele immer wenn
du kollegen die videos vorkommen sind
alle glücklich und alle am gute laune
ich bin nur coli die meisten brauchte